foreign
this is a person party that's your party
so this is where dignity Goes To Die the
year start coming and they don't stop
coming
your Puss in Boots let's talk
I don't speak Spanish either
you're funny uh what's your story my
story
what are we looking at cats have nine
lives watch watch watch watch
I think you said they have been too high
no I am
oh no
legendaries
waiting to be granted
I need your help is the great Puss in
Boots asking for help well you see yeah
okay please that wish to get me my
life's back okay okay pause on face I
won't make your bag but first
hey slow down I know what I'm doing
what what what's funny nothing should be
funny
everyone is looking for a Wishing Star
I'm going to wish for everything to be
just right
you will find your reward does not come
easily Puss in Boots Goldie Bears all
right
without life to spare I am nothing when
you only have one life that's what makes
it special go get him tiger hey take it
easy
this is gonna be fun
in the dark Forest we step through as
one ready one two after you wait what
dog
still alive let's go find out